'ecuador revive la nostalgia en las
calles antes de las elecciones generales
del 7 de febrero el recuerdo de rafael
correa- aún está presente en algunos
ciudadanos que clavan la vuelta al
socialismo
andrés heras representa la tendencia a
fin el expresidente correa un economista
de 35 años que implante a un programa de
ayuda social con la entrega de mil
dólares a un millón de familias
ecuatorianas ante la pérdida del 40% de
los ingresos a causa de la pandemia aquí
vamos a defender
una crisis económica sin precedente de
la que culpan al actual presidente lenin
moreno y demandan volver al viejo modelo
político
porque si él trabaja con el señor que se
ha asesorado por el señor correa porque
él sí fue un señor hay muchas personas
que están tratando de después de esta
pandemia recuperar lo que es el comercio
entonces sí sería muy bueno que les
ayude para así poder fomentar otra vez
lo que es su capital su ingreso para
seguir pues en el día a día
del otro lado de la acera el programa
social de andrés zarautz es cuestionado
por su principal contendor el candidato
de derecha y banquero guillermo lasso es
una propuesta en el aire hueca con
dinero que no le pertenece al gobierno
ese dinero del banco central le
pertenece a los depositantes de la banca
a las a los municipios a las prefecturas
y al sistema de seguridad social del
ecuador por lo tanto ese no es un dinero
de propiedad del gobierno el actual
presidente del inh moreno también se
presentó como partidario de rafael
correa antes de su giro político
que con andrés araos aseguran no
repetirán